president Penn State fraternity faced
criminal charges including involuntary
manslaughter and aggravated assault
linked to the death of a student pledge
Timothy Piazza was his name he died in
February after a drunken fall at a party
Beta Theta Pi fraternity brothers
allegedly waited about 12 hours before
calling an ambulance
a grand jury determined that Piazza died
as a direct result the extremely
reckless conduct of members of the beta
fraternity the fraternity's national
organization has now disbanded that
chapter it said in a statement it does
not tolerate hazing or alcohol abuse in
any form CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clayman is here with the facts of this
case this this case is heartbreaking
maddening and sad all at the same time
can you just start us off with the
specifics about what happened to this
young man
this case is one of the things that is
called heart-wrenching by the president
and the reason that it's heart-wrenching
is that this was a virtual 12 hour
period that was captured on video we
have to think of some of the things that
happen to this boy who arrives well
dressed in his khakis in his blazer to
do his last stage of getting into this
fraternity he has to run a gauntlet and
what that means quickly is that in
within two minutes they tried to get
these young people as drunk as they can
he is obviously really drunk when he
falls down a flight of stairs into a
basement now we have video that shows
him going up to the stairway and then
the next thing we see are four people
bringing up his limp body so what do
they do
they slap him around to try to revive
him they throw cold water on him they
strap books around his back so that he
won't fall over and choke and die in his
own vomit and they sent a text message
riki 12 hours before calling 911 to say
look there's been an accident this guy
needs help well what happened was that
they sent it route text message saying
they should 9-1-1 the young person who
wants to call 911 stall and telling him
that they don't need to do this this
boy's limp body is on the ground he is
stepped over by paternity brothers who
go to bed
and then ultimately he falls again again
again and he is dragged up the final
time and even then when he obviously is
bruised bleeding and is not able to
respond it still takes them 48 minutes
so what are the charges and they just
assume that you have eight people who
are charged with involuntary
manslaughter and aggravated assault
aggravated assault in Pennsylvania is a
20-year felony the involuntary
manslaughter is very simple in
Pennsylvania it is reckless or grossly
negligent conduct even from doing an
unlawful or lawful act so that means
there doesn't have to be any intent
proving also the term is being charged
the fraternity is being charged which I
find quite interesting the fraternity is
being charged and in the very long 72
page graphically harrowing sadly
describing this entire ordeal the
paternity is charged because it is said
that it knows an environment which
emboldened this kind of reckless
activity and what you see here in this
particular fraternity that was supposed
to be a model for charity is one that
was flouting all the rules since states
president is wait and he says this he
called the alleged details of what
happened sickening now announcing steps
to combat hazing so does that mean the
school could face legal legal action
well it certainly the school is not
involved in the criminal process but
ultimately you have the possibility here
of a wrongful death suit on behalf of
the family and the only way that they
get quote-unquote justice under the law
is either in money or in punishment so
would they go after the university as
well as the fraternity and the
individuals I certainly think that they
would even though the university can say
look we had a strict policy no hazing no
drinking thanks Ricky